Okay. Back here, check off another bird.
Just one left. Well, okay, I lied. It's not quite one left.
There is also scoring we'll have to do next, but one left for this part.
So all plays, like horizontal plays, takes a hand and the board.
What should it return? Well, it's going to be a set, the position in which we start the word.
Well, that can be the same as before, an i-j position is perfectly good.
Now, we're also going to have some words going across and some words going down.
Now, we want our results to be a three tuple.
It's a set of an ij position followed by a direction--across or down,
followed by a word, a set of those.
Now onto the all_plays function--takes a hand in the board,
it's going to return all plays in both directions on any square
so the play is a position, direction, and a word where the position is an ij pair,
j picked up row number, i the column number.
Direction is either across or down, and those will just be global variables.
We don't have to decide for now how to represent it.
I used a trick here--I said all the horizontal plays, the cross plays,
we get from calling horizontal plays directly on the hand in the board.
The vertical plays--I didn't have to write a separate function.
All I have to do is transpose the board--flop the i and the j, call horizontal plays on that,
and that gives me a set of results, but they're the results in the wrong direction.
They're ji pairs rather than ij pairs.
Now your task is write the code to put that all together
to take these two sets, one of them is in reversed order, so they have to be swapped around.
Neither set has a direction associated with it.
Assemble them all into the resulting set that should be returned by all plays.